this week on ford writer for the
atlantic johns hopkins professor and
founder of persuasion magazine author of
the new book the great experiment why
diverse democracies fall apart and how
they can endure yasha mung joins us on
forward this week
[Music]
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to forward
johns hopkins professor
author of the great experiment why
diverse democracies fall apart and how
they can endure and founder of
persuasion magazine yasha mook yasha
welcome thank you so much for having me
andrew uh well i've admired your
writing for quite some time uh you write
in the atlantic and some of the themes
you hit i mean your themes are
relatively diverse but they do tend to
center around
uh what you'd call classical liberalism
uh i would say is that fair i say
philosophical liberalism because
classical globalism always assumes you
want like really small government and
economic affairs where
you know i'm a little bit more in the
center left but yeah it's the idea that
the basis of a just society is giving
individuals rights and responsibilities
most people when you describe it that
way get on board
philosophical liberalism persuasion
community um so i thought your book was
really important and your book lays out
a bunch of challenges that i want to
describe to people
so there is a conception which is worn
out by fact that the united states is
becoming more diverse quickly um it's
projected to become majority non-white
circa 20
40 or 2050 around that time frame
and then in some quarters that's
presented as like a great thing and it's
like oh it's uh it's something positive
um and that narrative uh gets
oversimplified as something like
diversity is our strength
and then there's another narrative
that's like hey
uh we should be concerned about this
because you know that this is going to
affect our lives and there's some you
know xenophobia baked into that uh
sometimes you can see this
um schism in our politics where the
republican party is taking on a nativist
tone
and the democratic party is taking on
this
uh
diversity as good tone and you present
something i would describe as like a
middle ground which is like look um
diversity actually does have challenges
uh and that there is this tribalism that
can um in the worst of cases actually
uh
tear countries apart
yeah so so my starting point is that
what we're trying to do is actually
something really new and unprecedented
hence the great experiment that's a
great experiment yeah so so we
have had lots of societies in the
history of a world where pre-homogeneous
uh we've had lots of democracies felt
pretty homogeneous that succeed we've
had lots of democracies like the united
states that have always been diverse but
that basically worked by saying hey
we're going to give all the rights and
privileges to one group and then treat
the other groups really really terribly
as we did in the united states with
slavery what we haven't really done is
to have these deeply ethnically
religiously diverse societies like the
united states today in which we manage
to treat everybody equally which we
actually give
everybody real belonging and and a fair
shot
and and that is a difficult thing to do
for a number of reasons it's difficult
because it goes
in some ways against our human
psychology
we find it really easy as humans to form
groups and say this is our group and i'm
going to treat the members of a group
really well and everybody who doesn't
belong to the group really badly and
that's one of the starting points in
your book is that look not just
americans but human beings are groupish
kind of tribal and you can drive them to
be very very mean uh even with the most
ridiculous distinction
where it's like you just stick a color
t-shirt on one group another color
t-shirt and all of a sudden they're
persecuting the the uh other team very
quickly yeah i've done it with my
students who you know think of
themselves in some ways for good reason
as the most tolerant and open-minded and
they would never discriminate against
anybody uh and when you ask them as a
hot dog a sandwich and have a student
say yes and have a student say no and
when you have them play a little game
and the people who say that a hot dog is
a sandwich start to discriminate against
the people who say hot dog is not a
sandwich so visibility how can anyone
think a hot dog is not a sandwich i know
right you're not going to treat them
okay i mean come on
um
so there's lots of studies which show
would show this right but but it's
really easy to create those groups and
then we start to favor being group over
the out group and in real life those
groups are often along ethnic and
religious lines and so when you look at
some of the worst tragedies in the
history of the world
uh they were often uh because of that
claim rather i think or religious
conflict yeah from the holocaust to the
genocide in rwanda to lots and lots of
instances throughout history and so i
think we have to recognize that what
we're trying to do is actually really
difficult but ironically that might make
us more optimistic because at the moment
what i feel like so people say hey
how hard is it not to be a bigot you
know how hard is it not to treat people
badly how hard is it for people from
different parts of the world to live
together
it shouldn't be so hard if it shouldn't
be so hard and yet we have problems we
have real injustices in our society we
have real discrimination in our society
that means we're somehow uniquely bad
right we're terribly failing by the
standards of anywhere else but when you
read some history when you understand
psychology you recognize hey it is
actually quite difficult and
you know what despite our injustices
we're doing pretty well
relative to most of our societies in
history i think ironically if you
realize the difficulty of the experiment
we're in that also becomes grounds for
optimism about how well we're doing and
whether we can succeed i want to dig
into that because i think it's very very
important but people who are listening
or watching right now sense that you
have a bit of an accent you're a global
citizen
um so do you want to retrace your your
steps a little bit because a lot of your
examples in the from the book are from
all over the world
yeah so i'm uh so so my grandparents
were born in
what uh today is ukrainian territory
around leve
um
they were jewish uh they were convinced
communists grew up in religious families
but as teenagers you know became
convinced
uh of of you know wanting to build what
they thought would be a better society
they uh survived for holocaust in
uh
in in the soviet universe of course um
went back to poland to build up the
system there
realized that it was unjust and saw the
system turn on them and a big
anti-semitic program in 1968 my family
sort of scattered and i ended up growing
up in germany i was obviously an
interesting kind of
constellation
and men went to college in england left
a little bit in italy and france and
i've been living in the united states
now for quite a while i became a citizen
about five years ago so congratulations
making america a bit more learned i
would say i think you're dragging the
average uh
educational level up since i think you
have a a like a doctorate or some fancy
degree yeah i came here too you know for
grad school but i i don't know if that's
a good thing you know this is an
interesting thing but i think about
when i'm in the states right so we think
a lot about lacking diversity today in
america and that is a problem in certain
circles for sure
but when i look at the set of people who
i've studied with
who are my classmates who are my
students now or my friends and
colleagues in the united states it's a
pretty diverse bunch it could always be
more diverse but it's really pretty
diverse ethnically religiously and
virtually every way except for class
right as somebody who came to this
country as an immigrant to come to grad
school
i know very few people who didn't go to
fancy universities and are very few
people who don't have a graduate degree
and so i actually think that class
division in america at the moment is is
a real problem oh yeah you know and it's
uh
getting more ossified where there's this
horatio alger idea you could go from
ranks to riches but now it's tougher and
tougher because of
the the way the institutions have built
up um so you ask a really fundamental
question it's like hey how hard is it
not to be a bigot
and that there are a couple answers to
that question one could be like look
it's super easy not to be a bigot so if
you are bigoted then
uh we should uh
toss you out of society um the other is
that uh there is a degree of bigotry
baked in i'm going to share a bit of
experience i have so i'm asian you
probably gathered i grew up in in the
u.s
and i got
teased and
called out for being one of the only
asian kids my town all the time
um and so
for me like i
expect there to be a degree of tribalism
or even bigotry baked into most
interactions
which you know like may give me a
certain uh view of human nature but i
think that what you're uh
what you're saying here is actually
really profound which is look um instead
of treating everyone who
uh
has any trace of bigotry either internal
or vincing it as like somehow like an
outlier and ridiculously malignant
instead to say look
we should know that this is going to be
an ongoing tension uh and we have to
actually try and invest in managing it
look i think
that shouldn't be an excuse um to
indulge in our worst instincts right it
shouldn't be an excuse to say oh well
you know i have an irrational prejudice
against this group that's fine everybody
is bigot so let me indulge with
presidents right that's certainly not
what we should say but it should make us
a little bit more sympathetic to each
other um it should make us realize that
we all have our own flaws and when we're
all sitting in a glass housing we
shouldn't throw with stones
talking about this
divide between an educational and
socio-economically united states and
everywhere else one thing that strikes
me about america today
is just the disdain that a lot of people
in that elite class have for everybody
else we were like we are the tolerant
ones we have a progressive oh yeah is
wonderful it's so messed up and like the
average of a population is really
bigoted and it's really terrible and so
wrong you can't be a democrat i don't
mean in terms of a party as
multi-democrat you can't believe in
democracy if you think that most people
aren't capable of responding to moral
reasons most of the time and i think we
we all
have as in us we have this sort of
tribal instinct right even my students
have it uh how dare you save a sandwich
is not a hot dog and we also have the
better angels of our in of our nature
and so
the task of politics is to appeal to us
better angels of our nature so i ran for
president and spent a lot of time in uh
the midwest
iowa ohio
michigan
mostly iowa because of the mechanics
right and i can't tell you how many
people
uh in new york or california would ask
me about what people are like in iowa's
if they'd be like completely
right right uh you know backwards or
you know like uh
from a completely
another time uh and i found the people
of iowa to be by and large
positive delightful smart
uh engaged well-informed um uh so when
you talk about the these biases that
people have they're really strong and
and this is one of the things that
scares me the most about what's going on
in american life which is you have let's
call it the educated class the elites um
and
they do kind of uh look down their nose
that are condescending to what i called
in my last book normal people because
about a third of americans have a
college degree so two-thirds don't
so if you're
looking at two-thirds of the population
and painting them with a very broad
brush i mean like that you know that
ends up leading you in very negative
directions yeah and so for me when the
question becomes look you know when i
was 20 right i sort of thought hey
wouldn't be great to live in a society
where people don't particularly define
by groups right because something
irrational about these groups why should
you care about a particular group
because you happen to share an ancestry
or chapman to share some kind of
background
um and why should you treat somebody
better just because we're living down
the street rather than on the other end
of the of the earth so i thought you
know what we should
fight for is
is a politics where people don't believe
in nations particularly where
uh
you know they care as much about
somebody 500 miles away then the same
town
um but i think that's actually a
profound mistake yeah yeah you didn't go
that direction in the book
no and it's it's a mistake because of a
number of reasons the first is that
you've seen with donald trump and others
what happens when we leave the sort of
powerful symbolism
uh
and resonance of a nation-state to the
worst kinds of people
the fact that the american flag may
itself be politicized is something that
troubles me deeply
where
i was running a campaign and we used the
flag and then people like oh can't use
the flag it's like a trump symbol and
it's like like the flag's a trump symbol
right we're [ __ ]
exactly if we if we if we let trump own
the flag that is uh i mean substantively
terrible because the flag or she stands
for something beautiful but it's also
uh just politically terrible yeah
because it has a lot of power and if
he's the only one who's waving it
that makes him more attractive right um
so that's one thing and and when i just
realized how
difficult it is to care the same about
everywhere in the world and there was
this terrible shooting in the
subway in in new york a few days ago
i cared about that more than shooting
somewhere else not because i objectively
think it's more important but because
i've lived in new york for a long time
because i can picture the place and
picture the faces of the people on the
subway and and that's fine so the
fundamental question in an ethnically
and religiously diverse society is
how do we respect the fact that people
have these allegiances and will always
be defined by them but how do we also
get them to cooperate
yeah
and that's where philosophical
liberalism actually comes in right so
one way of asking this question is
where's the state versus the group
that's the individual
what should the relationship between
them be yeah and now there's some people
who are sometimes called communitarians
or multiculturalists who are basically
saying look you know we should think of
something like the united states just as
an association of associations but we're
not one country with 280 million or
whatever it is individuals and citizens
we are a country where there's you know
asian americans and african-americans
and whites and there's the uh you know
southern baptist church or whatever and
it's just a sort of conglomerate
of these different associations right
and i think that's a profound mistake
because
at that point
for example if you are born into one
group but you don't identify with it you
don't want to be defined by it or
perhaps you want to marry somebody from
a different group you don't want to
engage in the same religious worship as
your parents the state has no legitimacy
for coming and ensuring that you can do
that so what we need is two freedoms at
the same time
we need the freedom of
the individuals which includes the
groups of which where they belong
to be free from the oppression of a
state and attorney of majority right you
should be able to grow up without people
making fun of you for for being asian
american um
muslims should be able to go to mosque
jews should be able to go to synagogue
without fear of of attack we should be
able to criticize the government without
being locked up as people are in russia
at the moment for for criticizing the
the war with ukraine those are all the
sort of classical freedoms
um but we also need to make sure
that the state protects us
from what donald trump and james
robinson call the cage of norms but the
state protects us
from the way in which our own parents
our own priests or imams or or rabbis
our own neighbors might tell us this is
how you have to live and you know if
you're gay and our community thinks
that's a sin we're going to send you off
to conversion therapy if uh
uh you know we believe that sex before
marriage is a sin and you have a
boyfriend protecting you're gonna go and
beat you up right like protection from
the out group and protection from the in
group is the way you characterize it
exactly so we have to have this double
freedom and the only way to think of
that
is through a philosophically liberal
framework you have protections against
asian parents who tell you that you can
only
do one of three i'm kidding
i think that's you know good good uh you
know good health insurance that means
you can go see a therapist
but
yeah what what that means
is that
uh
the way that liberals should think about
groups is that we're always going to
have groups in our society and that's a
good thing we should value them
but we value them precisely because you
have a freedom to leave now most people
might not do that right you might make a
joke about it but you're going to honor
your parents you're going to feel that
that is an important association that
you have to live up to before you didn't
choose it that's that's fine most people
have a religion of their parents
for example but if you want to leave a
religion of your parents you have a
right to do that if for whatever reason
you want to cut contact with your
parents because you feel like they've
mistreated you you have a right
to do that and so the reason why you
respect groups
is precisely because we live in a
society where people can opt out of them
they choose and so that's the way to
respect the individual's respect groups
and to hopefully then have a sense of
common identity at the national level as
well
[Music]
here at ford we are passionate about our
mental health and i am so proud to be
sponsored by better help which can get
you
the online therapy the professional
trained therapist who's on call for you
that you've been thinking about using
but haven't actually gone ahead and done
your friends your family they are not
trained to help you it is not their
role
to listen to the things that are getting
you down but it is the role of the
online therapists at betterhelp
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
could not be prouder and because they
are our sponsor listeners can get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
yang that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash yang take charge of your
mental health like millions of other
people right now at betterhelp.com
you'll be glad you did and maybe just as
important your friends and family will
be glad too betterhelp.com
[Music]
so you talk about the pitfalls that
diverse democracies can succumb to
uh and you characterize them in three
buckets which i found to be very very
interesting
uh anarchy
domination uh and fragmentation and they
can take different forms but can you
talk about uh how these manifest yeah so
when you look at the ways in which
diverse societies have often fallen
apart in really cruel and violent ways
this is three of the key pitfalls right
so the first is a form of structured
anarchy
in which uh there's so many different
groups competing and being so
mistrustful to each other but they never
even managed to build a state or that
they undermine a state over time because
they say hey perhaps your group is going
to capture the state and that's going to
be really bad for me so let's just make
sure that there isn't even a strong
state to capture in the first place and
that helps to explain
what you're seeing today in afghanistan
what you're saying in somalia what
you're seeing in many places
where you don't have a good educational
system a good
health system where there's underfunding
in roads and all of those things because
there's this rivalry between groups now
one kind of solution to that
is domination which is to say one group
wins and imposes its might on the others
and that might allow you to sustain some
form of public order but it often comes
at
the expense of the groups that have been
dominated
and especially in its most extreme forms
that is um uh you know entirely
unjustifiable so you get slavery in the
united states and other forms of just
extreme exclusion of an exploitation of
of the groups that are dominated right
and then the third is what i call
fragmentation so the third is you say
look
we're going to have
this way in which we somehow try to
coexist in which we have a kind of state
we can do certain things but the most
important
decisions are going to be subject to
your particular group of communities so
lebanon is a great example there's not
really people who have a lebanese
identity and a lot of things that
are most important are not regulated by
the lebanese state but rather
the laws governing your marriage and
divorce and education and all of those
things will come from
within your shiite group or from your
sunni group or within your marijuana
christian group
and that's dangerous as well because it
actually often means that people have no
democratic control over many important
things because there's no sheer
parliament you just have to listen to to
your religious elders
and because it makes it really hard to
have contact between members of those
different groups i have two good
lebanese friends who come from different
parts of that divide
and when they got married in lebanon the
state for years wouldn't even
acknowledge their marriage because there
is no such thing as a lebanese wedding
there's only a wedding within each of
the communities so suddenly people from
different communities perhaps can't be
this bizarre from an american
perspective obviously
to the extent that these dangers are
present in the united states i mean
people can listen to that and be like is
it anarchy is it domination is it
fragmentation uh like which do you think
that we're most likely to be facing well
i think in some ways we're facing uh the
threat of each of them so obviously we
have had in our history a deep form of
domination and we're still feeling the
after effects of that
with disadvantages and discrimination of
african-americans for example i think
there is a danger of
a small form of structured anarchist
obviously we have a very powerful state
and military and so on we're not going
to completely fall apart
uh like some other countries are
there is research which suggests that
when you have a lot of ethnic energy
diversity and people don't feel a common
bond it becomes harder to sustain a
welfare state it becomes harder to say
hey we have we should have solidarity
with each other we start to think oh
hang on a second my text goes to people
like them over there rather than people
who are like me so why should i be
paying taxes why should i agree to do
that and third i think there is a real
danger of fragmentation a real danger of
sort of change culture in the united
states telling people the most important
thing about you is your is your
membership in a particular group
and that forms how you perceive a word
in such a fundamental way but you don't
really have a general connection to
members of other groups and so rather
than being
a society of american citizens but
respect each other we just become this
confederation of rival tribes
and one of the interesting things about
the book is that democracies actually
can
be more susceptible to conflict if a
group feels like okay
i'm never going to win in this uh
democratic process so i guess we'll have
to do something else
um it's one reason why you don't want
people to be falling into what madison
calls these fixed factions that that
don't shift or change yeah you need to
be able to think that you're going to
win the next election if you manage to
persuade enough people now there's two
kind of circumstances in which you might
lose that one is if you have such
inflexible ethnic divisions but
everybody always just votes for the
ethnic tribe and so actually persuasion
and policy programs and performance in
government don't matter part is just
becomes uh you know one question another
group yeah counting up for numbers right
and the other
is when you feel that if you lose an
election the other
party might become so oppressive or
might stop you from speaking out might
stop your free speech might might
constrain your influence so much but you
then will no longer have a fair chance
of winning the next election right the
brilliance of election i talked earlier
about
how they make things more difficult in
some ways but we also make things more
easy in one way which is to say hey
i lost this election i really hate it i
don't like the person who's in charge
but you know what i get another chart in
four years and so i can accept
legitimacy overrule because i have a
shot of winning the next time around
when people lose
their confidence in bad that becomes
really dangerous so there are a couple
of metaphors that you draw out in
question and then you present a new one
which i liked great deal okay metaphor
number one the melting pot people come
here and they assimilate and i will say
when i came of age the melting pot i
think was the
dominant frame in the metaphor now
people thought that that was a little
bit too
assimilationist shall we say and so that
got replaced by the salad bowl which is
that we're all in there and you have
different elements and we're kind of
doing our own thing and you say once
again there's a middle ground and you
call it the park the public park where
you go
you hang out with whoever you came with
but you interact with other people you
kind of bounce between groups how long
did it take you to come up with the park
it took me a while because you know all
the different metaphors you can come up
with tend to presuppose too much
commonality of purpose
so somebody was like you know what about
an orchestra
and that sounds beautiful you don't want
to be an orchestra and you can see the
point right you have people playing
different instruments but together it
creates a beautiful sound the problem
with something like an orchestra is you
will have to choose to play the same
piece of music and you all have to be
cooperating in this kind of way but
that's not how we think of it in the
free society it's just going yeah you
have your own purposes in life you're
not coordinating your purposes in life
of all the other citizens right yeah so
yeah look the melting pot was his
dominant uh idea and as you're saying
it's just asking too much of people
because it's saying you know even for
your culture might influence the overall
culture in the end will always sort of
be identical to each other and that's
asking to imagine it's also not very
attractive i love the fact that you go
around new york and you see these
different communities
that's one of the wonderful things about
the cities wonderful things about the
country now on the other hand you have a
sort of salad bowl of a mosaic and
that's basically saying people are just
going to live next to each other right
we're not going to have contact with
each other everybody is neatly part of
their own groups and that to me feels
too much like society is is falling
apart we have no points of common
contact and it's going to get oppressive
for the members of those groups because
they don't have a freedom to go and
engage with individuals from other
groups in the same kind of way and so
the public park to me is beautiful
because you know the two of us could
could choose to go and
sit in bryant park after this and hang
out
um and not talk to anybody else well
perhaps we'll play some i would love to
play chess um ask gary kasparov to join
us um and and perhaps we could go and
chat with some other people in the park
and and make a new friendship right so
you have the right to stay among your
own group or you have a right to to
venture out and we can say look that's
each person's right right if you're
armish in the united states you can just
live in the amish community you have
amsterdam that's perfectly fine that's
your right to be in good citizen no
problem at all of it but as a society if
everybody just chose to stay completely
within their own group if there was no
conflict between groups at all that
would be less attractive society i mean
i think the metaphor of a public park
expresses that nicely if everybody's
just looking down not talking to each
other that's a lot less attractive than
when you feel like it's a park where
there's also a space of encounter yeah
and you need to take care of the park
together or else you know you'll end up
with piles of garbage and the rest of it
it won't be
a place where people want to go and
convene
[Music]
[Music]
so you distinguish between two types of
patriotism which i found very
interesting first you think we should
invest in patriotism and i totally agree
and then you distinguish between civic
patriotism which you're probably higher
on than most anyone else because you
became a citizen five years ago took a
test you know all the stuff about checks
and balances and our constitution and
the rest of it i had a difficult really
difficult question in my citizenship
test actually we asked how many justices
on the supreme court and the problem was
that at the time there was a seed that's
vacant
and it doesn't say anyone you know it's
gonna be nine
yeah i said nine but i was like i said
like look i think look if you asked if
it's nine but you know and it's like
yeah yeah fine i've taken the right
answer go ahead yeah uh so yeah sure the
constitution doesn't specify a number
and there have been different numbers at
different points in time you're too
smart for this test so civic patriotism
you think falls short in a particular
way which i agree with a lot of
americans don't actually really
understand our system very well heck
i've been trying to explain how messed
up the current uh closed party primary
system is in terms of distorting our
politics and the rest of it and i have
to say you know it's easier to get
people excited about a thousand bucks a
month
i believe it
even though in my opinion nothing's
going to change unless we get the system
right but so i tend to agree with you
that there are limitations on this
appeal to civic patriotism and so then
you say you know what we should be
investing in is what you'd call cultural
patriotism so first of all look as a
german jew patriotism or nationalism did
not come naturally to me right i'm
deeply aware of
the the negative potential the negative
aspects that nationalism can have when
it becomes exclusionary when it becomes
militaristic when it becomes aggressive
and that's a danger that always remains
so i think of patriotism as a kind of
half domesticated beast that uh if we
leave it to worst kinds of people like
trump to exploit it becomes really
dangerous
uh we have to tame it we have to make it
useful um but it always will also have
that the dark potential we always have
to be look out for that the patriotism
is also the thing that can
tie us to each other right it's a thing
that can make sure that our society
doesn't fall apart it can be the thing
as we see in ukraine today
but can make people courageous but can
make millions of people say i'm gonna
fight for the independence of of our
country against this this terrible
invasion so it can really also be a very
positive thing but then the question
becomes what should it look like yeah
now it is culturally patriotic yeah so
historically one notion just put out was
being ethnic nationalism right was to
say we define who belongs by ethnicity
and that's obviously really and this is
uh you know trumpian temptation again
but continue yeah exactly that is to say
you know
white several americans and everybody
else is not and and that's
normatively wrong right because it
excludes a lot of people uh who have
great contributions to this country uh
it's also very empirically wrong because
most people no longer think like that
right most people uh uh
don't think that the only real americans
uh are white and the same is true now in
germany and france and
uh lots of countries in europe that used
to be different now normally what
philosophers you know i studied
philosophy in college um
and in grad school uh what they would
say is so we need civic patriotism we
need constitutional patriotism right if
we've got to have patriotism the only
way to make it uh sort of work and not
noxious is to say it's about our values
it's about our constitution
yeah and look that's great and and i
think it's an important element because
that's what makes it possible to be a
patriotic dissenter right with brave
people in moscow over the last months
who've protested against warsang not in
our name not in the name of a russian
nation that's a great act of patriotism
because
uh you can say our nation is about to
have values and when our nation divide
its first values when i'm actually going
to stand up against that so there's
something very important to that i think
we should have an element of civic
patriotism but when you go around iowa
and talk to people and say why do you
love america most of them are not going
to save a constitution and we're not
going to tell you
this is in the seventh amendment because
most people just don't care that much
about politics and so i think when most
americans say i love my country
what they love is the city they grew up
in the landscapes in the country
with sights and smells and sounds of a
country the kind of cultural script is
the way we interact with the way you say
hello everywhere you say goodbye the
kind of
just normal things of everyday life the
celebrities with tick-tock stars just
just the overall culture and that
culture is
might be influenced by the past in
certain ways but that is rooted in a
dynamic present it's looking towards the
future and it's diverse in a really
natural way and it seems to me that
most americans underestimate the force
of that they feel it actually but at the
abstract level they don't realize that
and so when we think about patriotism i
think we should defensively patriotism
but we should also be comfortable with
this form of dynamic inclusive cultural
patriotism there's a very big discussion
on i think this could be one of your
major contributions there's a rising
perception that america is
fractured into these different groups
and is also irredeemably racist and is
unable to
to reverse what you call the domination
the
vestiges of slavery and other inequities
and i think that this is something that
is increasingly
potent particularly on social media
where there are certainly various
marginalized groups i think the argument
i saw you make is that look
first like america does have problems
but if you view it as irredeemably
racist it ends up leading you to
negative places and so you should
acknowledge the progress and the
problems that are
real things that you can try and rally
around and celebrate and if you cast
these things more positively then it
actually is more constructive it will
lead you to better places than if you
see us as permanently fractured i talk
in the book about the way in which many
diverse societies have been marked by
domination and
how that has really long-term effects
and that's obviously true in the united
states with slavery as well as with
other injustices and so today we
continue to pay the price for that it's
because of that history of injustice but
african-americans earn less than average
but there's a significant wealth gap so
i don't want to pretend that everything
is fine
but there is also a weird kind of
pessimism at the moment on which the
extreme right and large parts of the
left and not supposed to mainstream
frankly touch so you know somebody on an
ethno-nationalist right is going to say
hey the reason why marcus historically
being great
is that its dominant group was so
wonderful because white and christian
and whatever else and you know all these
immigrants coming in today they're
somehow inferior the mainstream in the
left is going to say well that's really
offensive and and wrong
and blaming the groups but a
disadvantage for the misfortune is
perverse and i agree obviously with that
complete rejection of the causal
attribution on the right but then a lot
of people in the mainstream in the left
are going to say something similar which
is look you know italian and irish
everyone's 100 years ago they could
succeed
because they were white and were treated
well but immigrants today were
discriminated against so badly but they
don't stand a shot and so actually we
are failing at integrating people we are
failing at allowing minority groups to
make socio-economic progress now there
obviously is ongoing discrimination and
and racism that's absolutely clear but i
looked at some of the best empirical
studies on this and they showed a very
different picture the best study by
economists at stanford and princeton and
other places with over a million data
points i know you like data
shows that actually it's a slow process
of integration it was slow in with
italian and irish immigrants 100 years
ago it took a while until they earned as
much as the average of a population but
integration and socioeconomic progress
today for immigrants from
mexico and el salvador and vietnam and
kenya and all kinds of places around the
world
is about as fast as it was for italian
and irish immigrants 100 years ago now
what does that show us
it shows us that those people on the far
right are wrong to say that somehow
today's crop of immigrants is less
hardworking or less talented or less
capable of integrating when italian and
irish immigrants 100 years ago but it
also shows us that the narrative
according to which our society just is
so discriminatory that people don't
stand a chance
is thankfully also wrong and that's
something that we should be though we
should be happy about
now when you look at african-americans
you get a mixed picture where
there's a substantial number of
african-americans who are living in
concentrated poverty which is explained
by a public history of injustice and
that's an injustice where we really have
to struggle against but you also see
that donald trump was wrong when he
turned to black voters and said
you got nothing to lose right that was
not only offensive it was wrong because
the median african-american today has
gone to college for a few years it lives
in a relatively affluent suburb has a
white collar job has employer sponsored
health insurance and by the way is more
optimistic about the future than the
average white american and so despite
the injustice that definitely exists
this idea of a present state of reality
as an unmitigated dystopia
just happens to be wrong
oh well that's optimistic um and i would
say practical because one one of the
things if you say look you know america
is irritatingly racist like what do you
do with that belief at that point it
becomes
uh you know like hard to to head in a
positive direction um some of the
studies you say in the book i found very
interesting which is that
contact with members of different groups
different ethnic groups in particular
doesn't necessarily improve your
attitudes unless there are a bunch of
things in place
uh and so i i thought that was
fascinating because a lot of people
imagine that if you're just exposed to
other groups you're going to be less
biased against them but it turns out it
needs to be a certain type of exposure
yeah and i think
the really deep body of literature on
this can teach us a lot about how to set
up our institutions today there's a
thing called intergroup contact theory
which basically says hey
you know if you
are aware of some group you don't
actually have contact with members of
them it's very easy to be prejudiced and
say oh they must be terrible then once
you you know have contact with them and
perhaps work together perhaps have
neighbors uh you're gonna have a more
positive view and there's lots of
striking examples of that so one of the
first classic studies was
uh looking at different housing blocks
in boston one that was segregated one
that was integrated and it turned out
that when we integrated housing block uh
whites had a much more positive opinion
of african-americans and was segregated
ones were much more bigoted right
but uh over 50 years we've also found
that the situations where that mechanism
fails there's lots of situations where
the mechanism fails and for it to
succeed we need to have equal status in
some situation we need to actually be
part of the same team we can't uh
either be or be framed as being in the
right competition with each other in
some kind of way the ideal scenario is
you know you take a bunch of 12 year
olds and you put them on the same sports
team being the same league competing
against each other doesn't work but
being on the same team you've got to win
together you've got to hold together
that's why sports is important that
really actually
works people are going to end up having
much more positive views of each other
much as likely to to be prejudiced it
sounds like if you put them on different
teams it sounds like in a military unit
would be the same dynamic yeah so the
military is very effect is very
effective at that for the same for the
same reason now but that's why i'm
concerned for example
when
a lot of the pedagogy where we now have
uh in american schools especially in
elite private schools
uh tries to tell people the most
important thing about it is that you're
different from those others that is
exactly the opposite of what you do when
you take this body of research seriously
when you have teachers coming in
and taking kids that are six or eight
and saying we're going to put you into
different affinity groups because the
most important thing about you is that
you're black or you're asian american or
you're white
that frames to them we're not part of
the same team we're competing in some
kind of way and then all of those
mechanisms of ingroup favoritism and
outgroup discrimination kick in so i
know that the hope is that even take
these white kids and you know you tell
them about the purchase when they enjoy
that are unfair and the injustice of
american society and hopefully you're
going to come out being anti-racist i
really worry but when you take these
eight-year-old white kids and say the
most important thing about you is that
you're white and so on they're going to
end up saying all right so let's fight
for the interest of whites that is the
worst kind of
outcome
and i fear that we're creating the wrong
society through that and that if you are
a young person of color you think okay
the main thing people see about me is my
race uh and
and so that also can form like a
different kind of attitude which frankly
i've heard about from friends children
uh in new york city schools
where like some someone will come back
and say essentially like all my
classmates are racist
and then you're like oh well like how
did this come about and it was well
because of like the fact that they got
separated into various groups and then
started to see their classmates as
racist which i dare say is a terrible
thing for an eight-year-old to
experience um and uh you know like is
there racism you know among kids like i
i
yes but i i don't think that process is
going to make it better to your point
yeah you you need to
you know visit the argument of book but
to make a diverse democracy work you
have to understand some of the pitfalls
and you have to understand some of the
basic psychological mechanisms
[Music]
[Music]
you're saying that the studies would
indicate that separating people into
those groups would accentuate their
differentness and not mitigate yeah
there's actually one interesting study
uh that came out recently which shows
that if you take white kids and you give
them a lecture on white privilege then
they perform worse on the implicit
association test afterwards so it has
exactly the opposite of the intended
effect rather than being more tolerant
towards the out group they become more
likely to even have negative views about
different athletes well that's a that's
a very powerful data point
i will say i've got two boys who are
nine and six um and for them to be sat
down and talked to about race
um does not strike me as
a good thing because i don't think they
really can understand or process what
the heck
you know is being taught to them and so
it's going to give them some overly
simplistic ideas that
um that that they're probably not going
to make good you know good use of yeah
and look i think there's ways of of
teaching things in an age-appropriate
way that might be fine the problem of
course is you know is the average
teacher going to do that in the best
possible way um and you never know about
that but but i think just splitting kids
into these groups it's very different
when you talk about high school and it's
15 16 year olds who are saying i choose
to join some kind of after-school club
yes base that's freedom of association
that's that's the normal grouping of
societies it's self-chosen but for the
teacher to come in and say hey
six-year-old kid the most important
thing about you is the color of your
skin and so we're going to put you in
that group because that's who you are
that concerns me and you make a larger
point about
not seeing demographics as political
destiny and that doing so actually ends
up leading you towards polarization uh
and division and that if you're going to
make an argument for policies you
wouldn't necessarily center it on
someone's racial identity you probably
would want to do it around class yeah
this is one of the really weird things
in american politics today i mean
democrats and republicans don't agree on
anything liberals and conservatives
don't agree on anything they agree on
this one thing which is a really
destructive speculative
wrong theory about the future of his
country yeah which is that demography is
destiny and you see this on the left and
the right right so you see on the right
this idea that hey white people vote for
republicans but but other groups are
less likely to vote for republicans as
we have more immigration as we have
demographic change we're always going to
lose
so
let's put somebody like trump in who's a
wrecking ball let's do anything we can
to disenfranchise people let's keep
people out of a country it drives that
demographic panic on the right but then
it also drives this sort of triumphalism
on the left that some of your
competitors in the democratic primary in
2020 had really strong we don't have to
convince anybody we don't have to
moderate in order to appeal to where
voters actually are we just have to
uh mobilize some imaginary group of
voters who are all for us anyway because
of the color of their skin then we're
going to miraculously win and then they
get really really confused and annoyed
if like for example latinos don't all
uniformly go to knox step for the
democrats i just read another report the
other day which was basically saying why
are latinos voting for republicans in
greater numbers because uh there's this
like racialized misinformation that
we're falling for so the bases like all
internalized white supremacists
and it's like you know perhaps if you
want to win over latinos listen that's
so ridiculously condescending it's crazy
yeah exactly
it's it's you know oh like no
sorry you're voting for us it's because
you're a bigot oh how you do you think
that then gonna more likely to vote it's
really important for democrats to
persuade latinos to vote for them i know
you have other interests perhaps of the
forward party but you know i don't want
donald trump to get re-elected in 2024 i
want the teams to vote for democrats
it's not going to happen if a democratic
party
condescends
to latinos in that kind of way and so
but thankfully it's a good thing
that this idea of the rising demographic
majority is is actually wrong we saw it
in 2020 because the only reason why
donald trump was competitive was that he
increased his share of a vote among
non-white voter groups among
african-americans among asian americans
especially among latinos and the only
reason why joe biden won is that he did
much better than hillary clinton among
white voters in 2020 compared to
to 2016. and it's also not true in how
people actually identify
themselves uh you know there's a lot of
mixed-race americans now there's a lot
of people who
uh feel more in a more complicated way
than this sort of very easy division of
society into whites and people of color
on the other hand
uh would suggest and that's a good thing
i don't want to live in a country where
30 years from now i can walk down the
street
look at the color of somebody's skin and
say i know who you're voting for and by
the way even if uh quote unquote the
right party always wins because they
somehow managed to cobble together that
majority but they're still going to be
you know 47 percent of a different group
that keeps getting averted every time
and that's really angry and by the way
has a lot of guns that's not going to be
a good society for anybody to live in so
i really think this this whole idea
is really bad and we have to create a
politics
in which uh people
vote based on their values and based on
on their beliefs rather than based on
the affinity group um so
the way that gets framed customarily is
identity politics and it sounds like you
think identity politics uh does not lead
us in a good direction look for term
identity politics is so broad that it
really depends on what you're talking
about i think it's perfectly fine to
have certain forms of interest group
politics yeah right so it's perfectly
fine to say say we have like an armenian
american association that says we really
want the united states to
acknowledge the armenian genocide and
we're going to lobby for that it's
perfectly legitimate it's perfectly
legitimate to have
a kind of age-based identity the
american association of retired persons
fighting for the interests of of more
elderly americans it's perfectly fine to
have latino groups and african-american
groups and so on
that in asian groups that fight for
their interests like asian americans are
very fragmented but right yeah but all
of that is perfectly fine that's normal
we're always going to have that what i
think foe is that on top of these
different groups in society we also have
to have a common identity yeah what i
think is that when you start telling
people you can't understand me like
we're from different ethnic groups right
the idea we can't understand each other
i think it's really pernicious now you
might have some experiences that i don't
have and it's my duty as your fellow
citizen to listen to your experiences
when you say hey growing up i was mocked
learning asian market in these kinds of
ways i should have empathy for that say
hey that's an experience of life that i
didn't have that's bad what can we do to
remedy that what can we do to make sure
that your kids don't have the same
experience
that's my duty as a citizen but this
idea that i can't understand what you're
telling me about your experience and i
can't understand the political
implications of that which is that
that's a violation of the principles but
i believe in and though we can't then
have genuine sort of that you're saying
let's fight together to make a society
that accords to our values better when
it does at the moment that to me is
really perverse and sometimes when
people talk about identity politics
that's the kind of rhetoric we're
engaging in but you don't win majorities
like that politically but it's also just
a really dystopian view of a possibility
of communication between people of ways
in which
uh we are supposedly so deeply defined
by by our ethnicity but we just can't
communicate as human beings i that goes
against my deepest beliefs of human
equality
one other example you pose in the book
is around this phenomenon of accusing
people of cultural appropriation
and you pose that some degree of mutual
influence is actually very positive and
can help you build this cultural
patriotism in the sense of unity and
identity the term cultural appropriation
i think has such power
because
it often is applied to situations that
really are unjust
but it often misdescribes what makes
those situations unjust so let's take a
classic example right in the 50s and 60s
there was many really talented black
artists who didn't have big careers
because they couldn't perform in some
concert venues because
big record labels were uninterested in
in signing them up because of their race
now that's clearly unjust yes
and when those white artists sometimes
you took their songs and then had big
careers of them that's also wrong now
what's wrong about that what's wrong
about that is discrimination against
these african-americans uh the way in
which they should have had a big korean
weren't allowed to the way in which
white artists stole their work right
this is straightforward intellectual
property theft
but now that is described as cultural
appropriation and that makes us uh sort
of
think that any time that one group
influences another and perhaps
especially any time that
uh you know a more dominant group is
influenced by a less dominant group
somehow we should in general worry about
that
and that to me is wrong because one of
the wonderful things about this country
is the way in which different influences
come together from fusion cuisine to
old town road as a song that you know
has all kinds of different musical
influences and that is the history of
humanity there isn't a big cultural
achievement anywhere in the world but
doesn't have the influence of lots and
lots of different groups often when
people talk about cultural appropriation
they point to stuff that is unjustly we
should fight against but we should not
make the mistake of putting mutual
cultural influence under some general
poll of suspicion because that's
antithetical to what it means to be
human and what it what what it takes to
build a successful diverse society so
there's a period in the 70s when there
was like a kung fu craze and uh you know
like a a lot of ball players today have
for example have asian tattoos in their
body and i see this as awesome myself
i'm like oh i'm glad that
it's all like oh what are you doing with
like asian stuff it's like you know i'm
actually kind of pumped that our you
know culture is uh having an impact
in some way so you
in passing said something like hey you
have this
let's call it 47 of the population they
have a lot of guns uh and if you make it
seem like there is no path to victory
then things are going to get very very
negative violent destructive something
drove you to write this book um and
writing books takes a while so were um i
don't recommend it
i recommend reading the book i don't
remember writing books i know i mean
reading is more pleasurable than writing
that much faster too
uh so you must have been concerned um i
would say uh and i i've had a number of
democracy thinkers on this podcast which
is probably something you gathered
i had a joke where it's like hey if you
write a book about democracy
uh you know yang wants to talk to you so
one of the very consistent themes in
other countries is that you have when
you have conflicts is that you have a
dominant ethnic group that feels like
its status is threatened and then they
end up lashing out in various ways and
at the extreme end it can become violent
and ugly and that some of the most
extreme conflicts have taken this shape
and there are
elements of that happening in the united
states we should be doing everything we
can to mitigate against that phenomenon
here which includes what you're
describing is like not to like paint
everyone with a broad brush being like
you know you're white you're going to
vote this way you're like you're not
you're going to vote this way is that a
fair characterization of of like a
concern that you share yeah absolutely
so you know my last book the people
versus democracy was one of the first to
warn about the rise of populism and the
way that it really can be a threat to
liberal democracy um look at you taking
credit for calling it i continue no yeah
so you know i started i published a
first article about um declining support
for democracy in many democratic
countries and i believe 2014 2014 2015.
so this is before trump had won and so
on and people were still saying what i
was taught in graduate school was you
know yeah there's all kinds of countries
in the world but democracy is pretty
unstable but in the united states and
france and these countries that are
affluent but have had changes of
government for free and fair elections a
number of times
democracy is stable you can fast-forward
history 30-50 years and we'll still be
doing these and ours yeah and now we
realize that our democracy is in real
danger right oh yeah i know i'm that
stable so that's what i've been thinking
about for a lot of the last five or six
years and when i start to think okay one
of the reasons for this precisely as
you're saying is demographic change and
and the fears with bad causes and the
real difficulties with diversity causes
in a democracy so how can we deal with
those and how can we make sure that
people don't go nuts so that they don't
vote for these really dangerous figures
you know there's an election in france
very soon you know it's where yeah
and what what strikes me there is that
the marine le pen and the movie's
far-right figures have this really
pessimistic vision of what's going on in
the country i mean there's not a counter
vision that's optimistic from the rest
of society and so people say you know
what if everything is terrible everybody
is agreed with loving is terrible
perhaps you need somebody who defends my
group perhaps i should vote for these
people
what we need in order to avoid that is
to oppose really dark vision of politics
that something like donald trump has
with an optimistic vision positive and
unifying yeah but saying look it's hard
we're doing something hard here but
we're actually doing relatively well
we've made progress over the last
decades we can continue to make more
progress yes we'll always have different
groups and you know
uh that won't always be easy but we can
also have a real sense of common pride
in our country you know we can build a
society that most people whatever group
are a part of are actually excited to
live in and if we don't manage to do
that then precisely the worst kinds of
authoritarians are going to win so yeah
that there was a lot of motivation i had
for writing this book because i know
from my own uh family's history
what it means when diverse democracies
fall apart whatever societies fall apart
what what suffering that that means and
every generation of my
family for the last three or four
generations has experienced that in very
direct and extreme ways so the stakes
are really high
but we need a positive vision to to make
it work
[Music]
you close the book with uh something of
a prescription we've talked about some
of those recommendations already
investing in patriotism trying to avoid
these pessimistic
doom and gloom views where it's like
that we're irredeemable and that these
prejudices are so baked in that uh you
know combating them is futile to try and
uh celebrate progress you also i love
what you call the chapter 10 problem
which is by the way a total pet peeve of
mine that someone will spend nine
chapters uh painting a dark picture and
then when it comes to solving it you're
just like yeah
so you told yourself you're like i'm
gonna go strong
in terms of the recommendations um that
you champion so what are the big things
that we can do look there's a bunch of
things we can do as background
conditions right when you feel like
my economic future is bad i'm in direct
competition with other afghan business
groups the institutions aren't listening
to me the elites are looking down on me
then you're not going to be in the right
frame of mind to be friendly to your
neighbor who just moved in somewhere
different from you right if you
have a society in which you have a sense
i'm doing better than my parents where
my kids are going to do better than me
i'm getting a fair shake in the society
when you have a sense that we have
welfare state institutions that don't
say
what you get from a state depends on
your race but let's say actually
everybody who's in need
is going to get some reasonable level of
assistance um to help them succeed
when you feel that the institutions are
responding to me and they're taking me
seriously and not looking down on me
you're just much more likely to say hey
something you just moved in next door
let me let me help them let me be open
with them let me let me talk to them and
so there's a whole bunch of you know
grainy suggestions some of which uh i i
see eye to eye
on with you including institutional
reforms that can help us get there but
actually my most fundamental
uh optimism doesn't come from i came up
with this amazing idea and if only
people implemented when everything is
solved
it's from the development of society
it's that america is a much better place
today than it was 30 years ago when i
was born a majority of americans thought
that it was morally bad for
people from different ethnic groups to
marry each other now it's down to the
single digits
right this country has actually changed
a lot in the last decades and i know
that when you talk optimistically about
the present and about the future we're
likely to be able to get to
that can sound a little bit suspect
because a lot of pessimists say look i'm
just
shouting about being just things in our
society in order to fix women so if
you're saying oh but things are actually
all right but you want to blind yourself
to that injustice you don't care about
the injustice but that's not what it is
where i'm coming from is first of all to
make further progress we have to
actually know whether things are
improving or not if things are improving
then we can you know push from the
accelerator and and try to improve it
more if we're not improving at all we
have to throw out all of our principles
and start from scratch so it's important
to recognize but we have been improving
because it gives us direction for how we
can improve further and secondly it's
this political point but if you tell
people our society is so terrible but
nothing is working at all
then the pessimists on the right are
going to become
much more attractive and so yeah the
answer is there's a whole set of things
we can do at the political level but
actually most fundamentally when i look
at the politics i get worried when i
look at the heart of society i get more
optimistic and we've got to make sure
the politics doesn't screw up what are
largely positive developments in the
middle of america well i agree that
having traveled this country
uh the people are good
um and the political system is less good
is the way the way things are shaking
out and the media also less good where
the media really enjoys this demographic
destiny narrative uh they try and
racialize everything they try and make
it seem like there is this political
zero-sum game going and
one of my major complaints about the
democratic party is that they're buying
into this demographic narrative
and they're leaving places like ohio and
iowa where they were
very very competitive and saying well
this place is too white you know like 93
white like you know let's get lost
that's going to affect iowa most
prominently because iowa
people know this if you know american
politics at all like first
caucus state has its prominent place
it's probably where
it may well lose that prominence in part
because it's not a swing state anymore
it went from being purple a state that
barack obama won to now it's r plus
eight or nine
um and so the democrats are like well
why are we going to be investing here
because it's not a swing state and its
demographics are no good and what that's
going to do is it's going to accelerate
the bifurcation it's going to accelerate
the identity of the parties as being
very racialized where it's like look if
you're a white state you're going to be
republican and if you're a diversifying
state then we're going to come to you so
we're going to start investing in
georgia and arizona and just give up on
ohio and iowa because as long as we can
eke out a national win like you know our
ends are served and it doesn't really
matter people's lives are getting better
or worse
oh and that the country is more likely
to fall apart and end up
in this
racialized conflict
the case you're making is something that
i feel very strongly about because like
i see where we're heading you have these
institutions that just serve their own
incentives and needs
uh and
you know like the quality of life
is secondary like the people deserve
better to your point like people
the the people are good uh it's just our
leadership is letting them down because
it's become so institutionalized yeah so
for me one way of thinking about the
state of america today so we have a kind
of cultural civil war the elites
right you look at the top echelon and
people deeply hate each other
they're very very polarized but in
completely different fort worlds and
then when you look at society actually
people are much more reasonable they're
much more
sensible to various considerations and
there's much more overlap
so the question is is the deeply
polarized elite going to manage to
generalize its conflict and turn the
whole country into this
pitched battle between two different
groups
or
is
the bulk of population going to be able
to resist that imposition wow
i love that characterization at this
point i would put you know like
the average person
uh
in charge faster than i would uh some of
the people who are actually in charge
yeah so there's this famous old line
which i think is originally by a
conservative thinker but that i agree
with that you know i'd rather be ruled
by the first hundred people in the
cambridge telephone book when we
assembled harvard faculty and much as i
love my my friends who teach at harvard
i agree with that i think by and large
uh to be a small democrat to believe in
democracy has to be to believe to
believe that ordinary people are capable
of of decency and virtue and they
sometimes get it wrong of course
um but so do elites and and we have to
have that kind of trust so i agree with
that um you know populism
is a term
you know
it implies something but it's not meant
and it's used by so many different
people in so many different contexts and
so i sort of try to avoid the term
nowadays sometimes
um but but in political science what
what it is supposed to mean
is somebody who has two characteristics
one is that the anti-elitist which is
perfectly legitimate um you run in some
ways and anti-leaders campaign barack
obama ran in many ways an anti-adidas
campaign in in 2008 it's a normal part
of american politics or any democratic
politics to say hey some of the people
who in charge right now are doing things
wrong i stand for ordinary folks and i'm
going to do better for them that's the
normal thing what democratic politicians
can always say right
but there's always a second element and
that's a sort of anti-pluralism
that is saying you're either with me or
you're against me you're either on my
side or you're illegitimate
real americans approve of me and anybody
who dislikes me is not a real american
the best summary of this is evo morales
the
bolivian politicians uh twitter account
which is evo s pueblo
evo is the people so if you're not with
evo you're against the people
and that is something that does unite
uh you know from evan morales to donald
trump to victor arban
uh to narendra modi to to many really
quite dangerous politicians and so when
i talk about populism in my academic
work that's what i'm talking about i'm
not talking about listening to people
i'm not talking about doing stuff that's
popular i'm not talking about left
economic policy
i'm talking about
this is a politician who says
if you disagree with me you illegitimate
and that is a very dangerous mechanism
well congratulations on the book it made
me think about some of these problems in
a much deeper and different way
i think there is a lot of wisdom here i
hope people take your recommendations to
heart are you encouraged right now uh
josh you're in like the beginning of a
book tour
um
uh like
what what do you think i i feel like
people are coming
to some of the same conclusions that
you're drawing in different ways i think
there is a hunger to escape the
you know cultural civil war elites i
think there's a hunger to save a world
is a little bit more complicated
than the image you get if you just
listen to to one particular tribe and
uh buy into anything they say i think
there's a hunger for a slightly more
optimistic vision of a country another
future yeah um so yeah i'm i'm feeling
bad and hopefully if you're feeling that
and you read the book you can go and
give people even better arguments to try
and do that yeah again it's filled with
both wisdom and data the great
experiment why diverse democracies fall
apart
and how they can endure yasha mook yasha
thank you so much for being here thank
you it was a
pleasure forward with the yang yang is
produced and edited by mark finder media
and co-hosted by zach grauman jules
turpak me andrew yang and friends find
us wherever you listen to podcasts watch
us on youtube and subscribe today if you
like the show leave us a review on
spotify or apple podcasts and let's move
the country forward